-House GOP leader Kevin McCarthy
said he will not cooperate
with the committee investigating
the January 6th insurrection,
and one of former
President Trump's key allies
has a new plan
for proving
there was fraud
in the 2020 election
through virtually
the entire population
of the United States in jail,
but It wouldn't
sweat it too much.
It's not one of the regular
advisers, it's the --
Well, I don't want to give it
away, but he's got one of these.
You think you --
I think you might
know who I'm talking about.
It's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Well, this is my last
remote show
before I head back
to the studio next week
to be reunited
with the audience,
the crew, and more importantly,
cue card Wally,
who so many of you
have asked about
despite the fact
that he was never sick.
We showed Wally yesterday,
but it was pointed out
that could have been footage
from any day,
and to prove he was safe,
he'd need to hold up
a newspaper,
something with
today's date on it.
So Wally, can you hold up
something with today's date?
There you go.
He's totally fine.
I'm also going to be happy
to get back
to a place
that has proper snacks,
as I've been stuck eating this
non-medicinal horse pudding.
I got it in my feed store/
corner bodega,
only to find out today
from reading the label
it's not made from a horse.
It's made for horses.
And when you read
something like that,
you're just [blows raspberry]
Once again, I'd also like
to thank artist
Mary LaGarde for the sea captain
and Rihanna painting
that's been keeping me company,
although his interjections
haven't always been
the most helpful.
-Sorry, Seth.
I just like to have fun.
-Anyway, in the world
of actual news,
the Republican Party
has decided that
unless you're affirmatively
pro coup, you can't be...
-♪ A possible candidate ♪
-Thank you, Rihanna.
She's so wonderful.
It's actually helpful.
An interjection
that works as a segue.
You know, you could learn
something from her, sea captain.
-Sorry, what?
I-I wasn't listening.
-Alright, moving on
from that painting forever.
The Republican Party is now
affirmatively pro coup.
Nothing illustrated
that better than Ted Cruz's
humiliating performance
last week
where he went on Fox News
to beg forgiveness
for the grave sin
of calling the insurrection
a violent terrorist attack,
an act of self debasement
so pathetic
I thought for a second
he was rushing a fraternity.
What's he gonna do next,
streak naked
through a committee hearing?
And the Republican Party
and on right wing media,
you're simply not allowed
to say anything negative
about the attempt to
overthrow the 2020 election,
and you're certainly not allowed
to accept the results.
Otherwise, Donald Trump
will attack you and call you,
among other things,
a Republican in name only
as he did during a contentious
NPR interview this week.
-Why did Republican officials in
Arizona accept the results then?
-Because their rhinos,
and frankly,
a lot of people
are questioning that.
-First of all, there's no way
NPR listeners were prepared
for that interview.
Normally, to hear NPR,
you have to crank
the volume all the way up
in your car.
When Trump came on,
it probably set off the airbags
in every Prius
in the country.
The streets of Vermont were
littered with coexists stickers
that got blown off the bumpers.
It was like listening
to Terry Gross
interview a xenomorph
from "Alien."
-Welcome to "Fresh Air.
It is such a pleasure
to have you.
-[Roaring]
-I want to thank you so much
for talking with us.
Stay safe.
I wish you good health.
But that's what happens
if you're a Republican
who crosses Trump and accepts
the results of the election.
You get branded a traitor to the
party and purged from the ranks.
In order to please Trump
and the base,
you have to be willing
to go along with insane [bleep]
like this plan
from MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
to, if I'm understanding
this clip correctly,
imprison almost
everyone in America.
-I'm more optimistic today
than I have been yesterday,
the day before that.
I'm inclined like this.
Why?
Because it's so amazing
all the things that we have.
We already have all
the pieces of the puzzle.
And you talked about evidence.
We had enough evidence
to put everybody
in prison for life,
three hundred
and some million people.
We have that all the way
back to November, December.
You have enough evidence
to imprison everyone for life?
I'd love to watch
one of those HBO murder dramas
starring Nicole Kidman
with Lindell is one
of the detectives
who just burst into the room
during an interrogation.
"Ma'am, where were you
on the night of the murder?"
"And how many times did you vote
in the election?"
"Not now, Mike."
"But I have enough proof
to put her in jail for life."
"For the murder?"
"No, for election stuff.
And also you and me
and everyone else."
"What about the charming British
guy with the mysterious past?"
"[ Laughs ] Oh no, I like him.
I like him a lot because he was
in the movie with the bear."
So this is the kind of insanity
that has taken hold of the GOP,
which is different
than the kind of insanity
that has taken hold
of me...here.
Which is why investigating
the coup is so necessary,
otherwise they'll
just do it again,
which is also why Republicans
are refusing
to participate in any way.
For example,
the committee conducting
the investigation just asked
House GOP Leader Kevin McCarthy
for information,
and McCarthy said
he will not cooperate.
-House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy says
he will not cooperate
with the January 6th
select committee after the panel
formally requested an interview
with the California lawmaker.
The committee is seeking details
of McCarthy's communications
with then-President Donald Trump
throughout the Capitol attack
and in the days that followed.
McCarthy's refusal comes despite
his agreeing in May of last year
to cooperate with any sort
of investigation of the riot.
-Now, McCarthy says
he will not cooperate,
despite saying
that he has nothing to hide.
But GOP Congresswoman
Liz Cheney,
the committee's vice chairwoman,
will not rule out
sending McCarthy,
her colleague, a subpoena.
-No offense, but why are
they asking Kevin McCarthy
for information now?
This committee move slower
than the courtship
in a Jane Austen novel?
Did you invite him
via scented letter?
With that said, I do hope
they subpoena him,
mainly because
it'd be super funny
to see him try to hide
from the process server.
Although I'm guessing
the GOP conference
any of these guys
could be Kevin McCarthy.
How could you pick him
out of a crowd?
Even Trump
doesn't know his name.
-There was progress today.
I look forward to solving it.
-Thank you, Steve.
-Can't blame Trump for that one.
He looks like a Steve
to me, too.
If he were a character
in "Guess Who?",
that [bleep]
would be impossible.
And it would certainly
be interesting to hear
from McCarthy,
given that just days
after the insurrection,
he had this to say about Trump.
-The president bears
responsibility
for Wednesday's attack
on Congress by mob rioters.
-Oh boy, I'm guessing McCarthy
doesn't want
anyone to remember
that video.
"No, no, no.
That wasn't me.
That was that [bleep] Steve.
I hate that guy."
Of course,
that was just a few weeks
before McCarthy changed his tune
and flew down to Mar-a-Lago
to pose for photos with Trump
like they were
personal injury attorneys
who worked out of the Vatican.
Have you been rear ended
by the Popemobile?
You could be entitled
to compensation.
Call us at 1-800-1-Pope-Crash.
The S-H is for, shh,
don't tell nobody.
And McCarthy certainly seems
to have firsthand knowledge
of exactly what happened
that day, and in particular,
what Trump is up to,
given that by his own admission,
he spoke directly to Trump.
In fact, during
the second impeachment process,
a fellow Republican member
of Congress
relayed part of McCarthy's
conversation with Trump,
in which Trump expressed
his support for the mob.
And when McCarthy was asked
about that conversation on TV,
he just refused to answer.
-During the Trump impeachment
in February,
during the trial in the Senate,
a Republican
congresswoman said this.
I'm going to to put it up
on the screen.
She said that while
the January 6th riot
was in full force,
you phoned President Trump
and asked him
to call off his supporters.
And according to you, she said,
the president responded,
"Well, Kevin, I guess
these people are more upset
about the election
than you are."
Is she right? Is that what
President Trump said to you?
-What I talked to President
Trump about,
I was the first person
to contact him
when the riots was going on.
-But I'm asking you
specifically,
did he say to you I guess some
people are more concerned
about the election than you are?
-No. Listen, my conversations
with the president
are my conversations
with the president.
-No wonder he doesn't want
to answer questions under oath.
He isn't even good
at being evasive.
When you ask these guys simple
straightforward questions
about what happened that day,
they melt down and
sing meaningless pabulum.
Look, my conversations
with the president
are words that I spoke
from my mouth
that were then transmitted
via sound waves
and received by his ears.
As you know ears,
there's one,
maybe even two of them
and they're
on either side of your head,
the big round thing that can
be found on top of your neck.
Unless you're Rudy Giuliani,
in which case
it's attached directly
to your...
-♪ Chest ♪
-[ Laughs ] Thank you, Rihanna.
There have also --
[ Laughs ]
There have also been reports
that Trump and McCarthy
got into a shout--
We're going out on top
with the painting jokes.
There have also been reports
that Trump and McCarthy
got into a shouting match
on that phone call after Trump
refused to call off the rioters,
which makes sense
because they were doing
what Trump wanted them to do.
They were trying
to violently stop
the counting
of electoral votes,
which would have allowed Trump
to remain in power.
Again, it would be great to hear
from McCarthy under oath,
whether that was true or not.
Even former Fox News
host Chris Wallace
seemed to have an inkling
something suspicious
that happened
between the two of them,
as evidenced by this exchange
from later
in that same interview.
-I want to ask you
a specific question about this,
because there have been and are
continuing to be investigations
of what happened
on January 6th.
We'll talk about
the commission in a minute.
Has the president
ever reached out to you
since that report came out
to discuss what you
and he talked about
on the January 6th phone call?
And did you say to him,
"I can't because
we're under oath?"
-No.
-That never happened?
-It's never happened.
-And you --
-Never even close.
-And if it did happen,
you would agree
that would be witness tampering.
-Yeah, but never happened.
Never even came close.
Never had
any conversation like that.
-I will say Wallace
definitely seems to know
something happened between them.
He's leaning
into those questions
the way a parent grills their
teenage son about smoking weed.
"You would never do that,
right?"
"No, of course not."
"Because that kind of thing
could get you grounded."
"Yeah, for sure."
"And it would make
your clothes smell like weed."
"Oh...yeah."
"Like the socks
in your sock drawer."
"Uh-huh.
Wait, it was."
-I'm not saying Wallace knows
for sure what happened,
but to me it sounds
like he has...
-Enough evidence to put
everybody in prison for life,
Three hundred
and some million people.
-Get the energy of a guy
selling autographed
Pete Rose cards on QVC.
McCarthy won't comply
because he knows
Republican voters will reward
him for his allegiance to Trump.
Above all else, it's a movement
that is fully radicalized
against democracy to the point
where they're calling
for the imprisonment
of their political enemies,
which is why the various
investigations underway
need to do everything possible
get to the truth
of what happened and fast.
As for us, we'll plan to be back
in our studio next week,
and hope you've enjoyed
this little week-long
return to isolation
with horse pudding jokes
and sea captain interjections.
I haven't checked,
but I have to imagine
our ratings have been...
-On an incline
like this.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings over
two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.